.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
So, das ist meine Wohnung.
Sie ist ganz einfach und klein.
Das Bett,
ein Tisch, um zu arbeiten
oder um kreativ zu sein.
Kleiderschränke.
Und dort hinten ist die Küche.
Und hier ist noch das Bad.
Im Zentrum von Naera Giaimos Wohnung
in Sargans:
ein verhüllter Spiegel.
Er ist die meiste Zeit zugedeckt.
Einfach zu meinem eigenen Schutz.
Wenn ich mal irgendwie ...
... keinen guten Tag habe
und dann in den Spiegel sehe,
macht mich das manchmal
noch trauriger oder wütend.
Wenn er zugedeckt ist,
kann ich selber entscheiden,
dass ich mich bewusst anschaue
und mich dem stelle.
Für mich ist es noch
wie eine fremde Person.
Ich habe mich lange
mit der Krankheit identifiziert.
Und dadurch, dass ich jetzt
mehr zu mir selber komme ...
... ist es, wie eine neue Person
und Persönlichkeit zu entdecken.
"Liebe Magersucht, du begleitest
mich schon mehr als sechs Jahre."
"Du hast mir Sicherheit
und Kontrolle gegeben."
"Für mich warst du eine Freundin,
die immer für mich da war."
"Durch dich
habe ich das Gefühl bekommen,
mich und mein Leben
total im Griff zu haben."
"V.a. am Anfang unserer Freundschaft
hast du mich stärker gemacht."
"Du warst immer da für mich."
"Durch dich
habe ich in verschiedenen Kliniken
tolle Freunde kennengelernt."
"Das fast Schönste war aber,
dass ich ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt
keine Gefühle mehr hatte."
"Ich war dann nur noch eine Hülle."
"In den letzten Jahren hast du mei-
nem Leben irgendwie Sinn gegeben."
"Ich hatte eine Aufgabe."
"Du hast meinen Tag strukturiert.
Das hat gutgetan."
"Du hast mich nie alleine gelassen -
nicht während der Schule
und auch nicht zu Hause.
Vielen Dank!"
* Sanfte Klänge *
"Trigger Warning" - was heisst das?
Was ist da drin?
Ähm ...
Das sind Fotos,
die mich eigentlich ...
... in der schlimmsten Zeit zeigen.
Als ich relativ tief
in der Krankheit steckte.
Man sieht das
nur schon dem Blick an,
dass das nicht mehr ich bin,
dass ich keine Freude am Leben
mehr habe.
Wenn ich das angeschaut hätte ...
... als ich noch tief
in der Krankheit war,
hätte mich das getriggert.
Ich hätte das Gefühl gehabt:
"Oh nein, das ist nicht dünn genug."
"Ich muss noch dünner werden."
Das wäre ein Trigger dafür,
dass die Magersucht lauter wird.
Darf ich schauen?
- Mhm.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
"Hallo Magersucht, du hast meine
letzten Jahre komplett zerstört."
"Du hast meinen Körper
fast verhungern lassen."
"Wegen dir musste ich dreimal
mit Sonde ernährt werden."
"Während dieser Zeit musste ich
höllische Schmerzen aushalten."
"Einmal wäre ich wegen dir
fast draufgegangen."
"Wegen dir hätte ich fast
meinen besten Freund verloren."
"Viele Freundschaften
hast du zerstört."
"Du hast meine Familie überfordert.
Ich hasse dich so sehr."
"Keine Freude, kein Lebenswillen,
keine Kraft mehr und vieles mehr."
"Du hast mir so viel genommen."
"Wegen dir konnte ich die Flug-
begleiterausbildung nicht beenden."
"Ich habe so viele Partys verpasst."
"Du hast mich depressiv gemacht."
"Mein Selbstwert ist noch tiefer
gesunken, als er schon war."
"Du hast mir
so viele Chancen genommen
und hast mich nur kritisiert."
"Für dich war ich nie dünn genug,
nie krank, nie genug diszipliniert."
"Du wolltest mich umbringen
und ich habe noch mitgemacht,
weil ich dachte,
dass ich es verdiene."
"Doch tue ich das wirklich?
Who knows?"
Naera Giaimo ist 24 Jahre alt.
Mit knapp 16
trat die Magersucht in ihr Leben.
Es kam schleichend.
Als Erstes, das weiss ich noch ...
... mochte ich einfach nicht essen.
Und dann
habe ich irgendwie gemerkt ...
Dann erfuhren wir, dass jemand
aus der Familie krank ist.
Dort merkte ich dann,
dass, wenn ich nicht esse,
die Gefühle nicht hochkommen.
So hat sich das eigentlich ...
... manifestiert.
Dadurch, dass ich
immer weniger Gefühle hatte ...
... war ich noch motivierter,
weniger zu essen.
Zentrum für Essstörungen
des Universitätsspitals Zürich.
Seit fünf Wochen
Flavia Maiers Zuhause.
Es ist kurz vor Weihnachten.
In einer stationären Therapie
muss Flavia Maier lernen,
wieder zu essen.
Sie haben fast 4 kg zugenommen.
Das ist ein Erfolg.
Aber so einfach ist das für Sie
wohl nicht, oder?- Nein.
Die letzten zwei, drei Messungen
freute ich mich wirklich.
Ich musste sagen: "Hey, doch."
"Das ist der richtige Weg.
Das willst du."
"Es wird nicht besser,
wenn das Gewicht wieder runtergeht."
Es wird nicht besser.
Das habe ich erfahren.
Das muss ich mir
wirklich immer einreden.
Flavia Maier erkrankte mit 15.
Sie wollte beliebter,
interessanter, einfach anders werden.
Die Magersucht versprach dem Teenager
einfache Lösungen
für komplexe Probleme.
Ich glaube, am meisten
lockte mich die Bestätigung,
die ich durch nicht essen und
abnehmen immer wieder erhalten habe.
Diese habe ich von der Anorexie,
von der kranken Stimme,
die in mir drin ist, erhalten.
Diese Bestätigung, die mir von
der Aussenwelt nicht gegeben wurde
oder ich wenig hörte.
Ich konnte mich auch selber
nie für etwas bestätigen,
das ich gut gemacht habe.
Ich war mir gegenüber
immer sehr kritisch.
Und wenn auf einmal
der Kritiker nur auftaucht,
wenn du zunimmst oder isst,
und du das umgehen kannst,
indem du nicht isst ...
... ist das ziemlich anziehend.
Im Zentrum für Essstörungen
lernt Flavia Maier -
zusammen mit elf Mitpatientinnen -,
zu unterscheiden,
wann die Magersucht mit ihr spricht
und wann ihr eigenes Ich.
Welch verwirrende Dialoge
so entstehen,
können Gesunde kaum nachvollziehen.
Wenn die Leute das so sehen
und sagen ...
Sie sehen uns und sagen:
"Ganz normal essen."
"Wo ist denn das Problem?"
- Warum sind ...
"Die tun nur so."
- Mhm.- Ja.
Die Vorurteile,
die man uns gegenüber hat.
Ja.
"Du musst halt einfach mehr essen."
Das ist auch ein typischer Spruch.
- Ja. "Iss doch einfach!"
Es ist schon sehr ...
... sehr fokussiert auf:
"Es war zu viel."
"Dein Körper braucht das nicht."
"Jetzt musst du
bei der nächsten Mahlzeit weniger."
Aber nicht einmal per se
in Bezug auf das Gewicht,
dass ich denke,
dass ich zunehme, wenn ich so esse,
sondern dass ich meinem Körper
die Nahrung, die er braucht,
vorenthalten möchte.
Der Körper
hat die Nahrung nicht verdient.
Nein.
Warum?
- Er hat ja nichts geleistet.
Leistung,
Perfektionismus, Kontrolle -
sie bilden -
neben genetischen Faktoren -
oft den Nährboden,
auf dem die Magersucht gedeihen kann.
Ich wollte immer alles
perfekt machen.
Egal wo: Schule, Sport, Freizeit ...
Die Stimme der Magersucht
war immer in meinem Kopf.
Dadurch,
dass ich mal nicht gegessen habe,
sagte mir die Magersucht:
"Gut gemacht! Mach weiter so!"
Diesen Satz - "Gut gemacht!"
oder "Perfekt gemacht!" - dafür,
dass du nichts gegessen hast,
wollte ich immer mehr hören.
Einfach das,
dass ich etwas leisten kann.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Selfies, sog. Bodychecks -
die Trophäen der Magersüchtigen.
Die bildhafte Frage an die Krankheit:
Bin ich dünn und krank genug?
Die Antwort:
ein immerwährendes Nein.
In den schlimmsten Zeiten
konnte ich nicht mehr aufstehen.
Mir wurde dauernd schwarz vor Augen.
Mir war kalt, 24/7.
Egal, wie viele Kleider ich anzog.
Ich dachte mir oft, dass ich ...
... lieber nicht mehr
auf dieser Welt wäre,
weil ich nicht mehr konnte und
nicht wusste, ob ich es rausschaffe.
Sie wollte mich ...
... töten, ja.
Jeden Samstag
trifft sich Naera Giaimo
mit ihren Eltern zum Mittagessen.
Lange Zeit ist sie dem Familientisch
mit den unterschiedlichsten Ausreden
ferngeblieben.
Trauen Sie dem Frieden,
dass sie so isst?
Ich glaube, sie ist wirklich
auf einem sehr guten Weg.
Aber oft ging es stark aufwärts
und dann direkt wieder runter.
Irgendwann habe ich angefangen ...
... die Hoffnungen zu begraben, ja.
Und jetzt
bin ich einfach glücklich ...
Wir nehmen einfach den jetzigen
Zeitpunkt und jetzt ist es gut.
Schau, das habe ich noch gefunden.
Das sieht furchtbar aus.
Naera ist das zweitjüngste der sechs
Kinder von Silvia und Michele Giaimo.
Schauen wir, wo du kommst.
Du kamst natürlich später zur Welt.
Unsere Naera.
Dass ihre fröhliche Tochter
an Magersucht erkranken könnte
und fünf lange Jahre immer wieder
in psychiatrischen Kliniken,
in Spitälern und
auf Therapiestationen leben würde,
war für ihre Eltern unvorstellbar.
Du warst nicht fett.
Das war Babyspeck.
Das ist normal.
Es war eigentlich eine Achterbahn.
Irgendwie habe ich das am Anfang
nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe mein Gefühl unterdrückt.
Dann gab es wieder Tage,
an denen ich nur weinen konnte.
Und dann war ich manchmal
aber auch extrem wütend auf sie.
Ich konnte nicht verstehen,
dass sie sich so blöd anstellt.
Ich sah das so. Manchmal
hätte ich nur schreien können.
Manchmal war sie mir auch fast egal,
weil ich mich einfach
wie von ihr trennen musste,
sonst wäre ich draufgegangen.
Ich habe ja vorwiegend
die Fehler bei uns gesucht,
warum es so weit kam,
das ist ganz klar.
Wir haben sicher Fehler gemacht.
Das ist ganz klar.
Ich glaube ... Ja.
- Was für Fehler,
von denen Sie wissen,
dass es wohl falsch war?
Ein Fehler war sicher, dass wir ...
Eben,
dass ich sie am Anfang noch fast ...
... nicht unterstützt habe,
aber ich habe nicht gecheckt,
wie weit das geht.
Ich habe die Signale
nicht wahrgenommen.
Als sie das erste Mal
in die Psychiatrie kam, fand ich:
"Was will die dort oben? Die muss
doch nicht in die Psychiatrie."
"Die ist zu gesund
für eine Psychiatrie."
Ich habe es einfach nicht gecheckt.
Ich wollte es nicht wahrhaben.
Also,
wir haben viel zu lange gewartet,
bis wir Hilfe von aussen
angenommen haben.
Das ist ganz klar, ja.
Ich wollte mir nie sagen
bzw. dachte nie,
dass jemand daran schuld ist.
Es hängt so viel zusammen.
Es ist so komplex.
Guten Morgen zusammen.
Ich begrüsse Sie
zur Donnerstagsgruppe.
Ich würde Sie bitten, zu starten.
Wer möchte beginnen?
(Flavia) Als ich jünger war
und es meiner Mutter
oder meinem Vater nicht gut ging,
suchte ich die Schuld immer bei mir.
Das kam nicht erst,
als ich mit dem Essen
so ein Drama machte,
sondern schon viel, viel früher.
Unzählige erfolglose Therapien
liegen auch hinter Flavia Maier.
Je länger die Krankheit dauert,
desto kleiner
wird die Chance auf Heilung.
Gruppengesprächstherapie
im Zentrum für Essstörungen.
Thema heute: Schuldgefühle.
Ich verspüre
viele, viele Schuldgefühle
meinen Eltern und meiner Schwester
gegenüber, weil ...
Ich habe wie ...
Ich habe so viele Dinge gemacht,
die ich ...
Kaum hatte ich sie gemacht,
merkte ich: "Oh mein Gott!"
"Das ist das Schlimmste,
das ich machen konnte."
Dann entschuldigte ich mich weinend.
Ich fühlte mich so schuldig.
Aber in dem Moment,
in dem man es macht,
ist die Schuld wie weggeblasen.
Und die
überrollte einen dann extrem.
Was waren das für Dinge?
Sie müssen nicht ins Detail gehen.
Ich habe sie angelogen.
Ich liess vor ihnen
Essen verschwinden.
Ich bewegte mich,
obwohl sie Nein gesagt hatten.
Ich stritt mit ihnen
über die Portionengrösse.
Ja, ich machte alles, was ich
eigentlich nicht machen würde.
Vor acht Jahren hielt im Haus
von Markus und Gitte Maier
ein neues Familienmitglied Einzug:
Flavias Magersucht.
Diese säte Zwietracht rund ums Essen,
wo immer es ging.
Beinahe wäre die Ehe der Maiers
daran zerbrochen.
Um die ganze Familie - auch
Flavias ältere, gesunde Schwester -
zu schützen, entschieden
Markus und Gitte Maier letztes Jahr,
Flavia künftig nicht mehr
zu sich nach Hause zu nehmen,
wenn Therapien
ohne Erfolg abgebrochen würden.
Es gibt kein Auffanglager für
so schwer erkrankte junge Frauen.
Das gibt es nicht.
Sie werden einfach
auf die Strasse gestellt,
im Sinne von:
"Du kannst gehen. Help yourself."
Wir haben es schon ganz brutal
erlebt, als Corona gekommen ist.
Da stellten sie sie auf die Strasse.
Sie sagten: "Wir brauchen das Bett.
Sie können gehen."
Warum ist es kein Thema mehr,
Flavia hier zu Ihnen zu nehmen?
Wir haben es ...
wie viele Male versucht, Gitte?
Ja ...
- Wir haben es ein paarmal versucht.
Das Problem ist einfach:
Es würde gehen, wenn sie ...
... das, was wir ihr vorsetzen,
essen würde.
Wenn sie sagen würde:
"Okay, das nehme ich."
In der Klinik isst sie
zwei Stück Brot, bei uns eines.
In der Klinik isst sie Butter,
bei uns Margarine.
Das führt einfach dazu,
dass es immer Streit gibt.
Das geht nicht.
Die Emotionen explodieren
und dann schreien wir uns an.
Und das
gibt keinen fruchtbaren Boden.
Und irgendwie haben wir
auch keine Kraft mehr.
Wir können nicht mehr.
Wir sehen natürlich immer unser Kind
in dem Ganzen.
Das Kind, das wir über alles lieben,
das ein Wunschkind ist.
Und man sieht,
dass das Kind am Tisch verhungert.
Auch die Selbstvorwürfe darüber,
dass man nicht damit umgehen kann,
dass man nicht fähig ist,
das zu begleiten.
Aber es geht nicht.
Diese Kraft fehlt einfach.
Mit der Magersucht sind
auch viele Fachleute überfordert.
Betroffene - zu 90 % Frauen -
fallen nicht selten durch die Maschen
unseres Gesundheitswesens:
Ihr Body-Mass-Index ist für
psychiatrische Einrichtungen zu tief,
für die Akutspitäler wiederum
sind die Patientinnen zu wenig krank.
Dabei hat die Magersucht -
mit 5 bis 10 % -
eine der höchsten Sterblichkeitsraten
aller psychischen Krankheiten.
Betroffene sterben an Herz-
oder Multiorganversagen
oder an Infektionen.
Ich sass mal am Morgentisch
im Spital, hatte mein Brot ...
... kaute es und wollte schlucken
und dann gab mein Schluckmuskel
einfach auf.
Ich konnte
einfach nicht mehr schlucken.
Alles war so runtergefahren.
Flavia Maier mit 14 Jahren.
Die folgenden verstörenden Bilder
ihres ausgehungerten Körpers
entstanden vor gut einem Jahr.
Flavia wog noch 24 kg.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Ich war mega hoffnungslos
und dachte:
"Du bist so oft aufgestanden
und wieder hingefallen
und wieder aufgestanden
und wieder hingefallen,
es wird nicht klappen."
"Du wirst es nicht schaffen."
Ich war fest davon überzeugt,
dass das niemals aufhören wird,
dass ich niemals
wieder normal werden kann.
Ich fand, ich sterbe besser,
als so weiterzuleben.
Flavia war in diesem Programm
in einem sehr schlechten Zustand.
Die Ärzte
machten sich wirklich Sorgen.
Sie sagten: "Wir müssen reagieren,
sonst stirbt Ihre Tochter."
Sie holten uns für ein Gespräch und
stellten uns vor die Entscheidung,
weil wir eine Patientenverfügung
haben für unsere Tochter ...
... ob wir bereit dazu seien,
sie nochmals parenteral zu ernähren
und ihr das Leben zu retten.
Wären wir dazu nicht bereit gewesen,
hätten sie sie
auf eine Palliativstation verlegt,
damit sie hätte sterben dürfen.
- Mit 22.- Mit 22.
Wir gingen nach Hause und haben
eine Nacht darüber geschlafen.
Wir haben uns wirklich
mit dem Gedanken auseinandergesetzt.
Wir haben uns überlegt,
ob wir das noch einmal wollen.
Wir entschieden uns dazu: "Flavia,
du bleibst auf dieser Welt."
Magersüchtige können nicht essen.
Ihr Nicht-Essen
ist keine freie Entscheidung,
sondern Ausdruck
der Krankheit Anorexie.
Doch unter Ärzten fehlt es an Wissen.
Eine Quelle steten Ärgers
für die leitende Ärztin
Gabriella Milos.
Es ist wichtig,
dass man die Anorexie sieht ...
... wie, sagen wir,
eine schwere Leukämie.
Das sind Erkrankungen,
die kein gutes Outcome haben.
Es sind schwerwiegende Erkrankungen,
die junge Leute betreffen.
Für mich ist es schwierig,
das zu sehen:
Bei einer 20-Jährigen
mit einer schweren Leukämie
würde man alles machen,
um diese Person zu retten.
Bei einer 20-Jährigen mit Anorexie
findet man:
"Ja, sie soll nur essen."
Und das ist etwas,
bei dem wir uns alle
engagieren müssen,
damit diese Krankheiten ernsthaft
erkannt und auch behandelt werden.
Leider ist es so, dass es
effektiv viele Somatiker gibt,
die das viel zu wenig ernst nehmen.
Auch Naera Giaimo
hat dem Tod ins Auge geblickt.
Die Magensonde, mit der
die damals 21-Jährige ernährt wurde,
hatte innere Verletzungen verursacht.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Nach der Gastroskopie wachte ich
auf der Intensivstation auf.
Ich weiss noch, dass die Ärzte und
eine Pflegefachfrau vor mir standen.
Sie gab mir dann eine Maske.
Dann waren plötzlich alle weg
und ich war
wie in einem Dämmerzustand.
Ich war gar nicht mehr richtig da.
Dann schaute ich an die Decke hoch.
Dann kam plötzlich ein Licht.
Also, so ein mega helles Licht.
Und das zog mich wie nach oben.
Ich weiss noch,
dass es mega ruhig war.
Ich hörte weder ein Piepsen,
noch eine Stimme.
Ich habe nichts mehr gehört.
Und es war ganz warm.
Und das Licht
zog mich immer weiter nach oben.
Und irgendwann, ich schätze,
nach ein paar Minuten ...
... kam eine Stimme,
die sagte, ich müsse zurück.
Ich hätte noch eine Aufgabe.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ihre Aufgabe
kennt Naera Giaimo noch nicht.
Fakt ist aber:
Nicht einmal diese Nahtoderfahrung
konnte die Stimme der Magersucht
zum Schweigen bringen.
Ich verleugnete es oft,
weil mir die Magersucht immer sagte,
ich sei nicht krank.
Oft erzählte ich auch,
dass es jemand anderem passiert sei
und nicht mir.
Naera ist dankbar, am Leben zu sein.
Dankbar ist sie
auch ihrem besten Freund Alex,
der ihr als Einziger
die Treue gehalten hat.
Du kamst mich in jeder Klinik
besuchen.
Mhm.
Du kamst immer.
Du warst auch der,
der mich hingefahren hat.
Du hast mich ins Spital gebracht,
das zweite Mal.
Es ist,
als wärst du in ein Loch gefallen.
Ich stehe oben ...
... strecke meine Hand runter
und ...
... es sind 10 m dazwischen.
Ich kann dich nicht hochheben.
Und trotzdem
hast du es irgendwie geschafft.
Als ich dann verstand, was
in deinem Kopf vorgehen könnte ...
... habe ich nicht mehr
daran gedacht ...
... die Freundschaft zu künden.
Es hat sich definitiv ...
... extrem gelohnt.
V.a. auch, wenn man ...
... an einem gewissen Zeitpunkt
dachte,
es gehe nicht mehr lange.
Darum freut es mich noch mehr,
sie jetzt so zu sehen.
Ja.
Von aussen sieht man Naera Giaimo
ihre Krankheit nicht mehr an.
Umso überraschender:
Die Magersucht gibt ihr im Alltag
noch immer den Takt vor.
Es ist abends um 18 Uhr.
Was haben Sie heute
schon alles gegessen?
Heute noch nichts.
- Noch gar nichts?- Nein.
Es ist einfacher, abends zu essen.
- Wieso ist es einfacher?
Weil ich dann schlafen gehen könnte.
Wenn ich starke Gefühle habe,
wenn es starke Gefühle auslöst
oder ich mich
dann irgendwie nicht wohlfühle,
weiss ich, dass ich im schlimmsten
Fall schlafen gehen könnte.
Und sonst, wenn es
keine Gefühle auslöst, umso besser.
Aber ich hätte sozusagen diese ...
... Notlösung.
Einmal pro Woche trifft sich Flavia
Maier, die von einer IV-Rente lebt,
mit ihren Eltern.
Es ist kalt, die Restaurants
sind wegen der Pandemie geschlossen.
Man trifft sich
in der Wohnung von Flavias Schwester.
Die Stimmung ist gedrückt:
Flavias Gewichtszunahme
stagniert seit Wochen.
700 g pro Woche müssen es sein,
sonst droht der Abbruch der Therapie.
Was wäre, wenn Sie austreten müssten?
Wie ginge es weiter?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Meine Therapeutin meinte,
dann müsste ich in ein Pflegeheim
und dort schauen, ob ich
meine Strukturen beibehalten kann.
Was macht das mit Ihnen,
wenn Sie "Pflegeheim" hören?
Es sträubt sich alles in mir drin.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich das machen
oder sonst etwas suchen würde.
Vielleicht gibt es auch
eine günstige Wohnung oder so.
Aber dort weiss ich:
Ohne jegliche Unterstützung ...
... wird es nicht funktionieren.
Dann stehe ich früher oder später
wieder am gleichen Punkt.
Das Haus der Eltern
steht ihr nicht mehr offen,
zu heftig sind die Streitereien
des Essens wegen.
Ich weiss, dass sie sich Sorgen
machen, dass es ihnen Mühe macht.
Bei mir kommt das so rüber:
"Wir können nicht mehr
für dich da sein."
Das tut enorm weh, aber ich weiss,
dass es nicht gegen mich geht.
Haben Sie Verständnis dafür,
dass Sie nicht nach Hause können -
also zum Wohnen, zum Leben?
Wenn es mir so geht,
dass ich nicht genug
gegen die Krankheit kämpfen kann,
verstehe ich es, ja.
Zuzusehen ist, glaube ich,
das Schlimmste.
Zehn Tage später, frühmorgens im
Zentrum für Essstörungen in Zürich:
der schicksalhafte Gang zur Waage.
Was hat die Waage gesagt?
Es war nicht gut.
Es hat nicht für das gereicht,
was ich hätte erreichen müssen.
Was bedeutet das?
Vermutlich, dass es wieder
ein Standortgespräch gibt
und sie mir wieder
eine Auflage geben werden.
Die muss ich wieder
jede Woche erreichen.
Das wird für mich
wieder ein enormer Stress und Druck.
Unter welchen Voraussetzungen
kann sie
aus dieser Krankheit herauskommen?
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass die
Patienten lernen, zu unterscheiden,
was Gedanken und Handlungen
der Krankheit sind.
Und was ist das,
was ich gerne machen würde?
Je besser eine Patientin die beiden
Seiten unterscheiden kann ...
Wenn sie z.B. denkt:
"Es sträubt sich alles dagegen,
ich würde diese - sagen wir
Teigwaren - überhaupt nicht essen",
dann aber erkennen,
dass das meine Krankheit ist
und dass die dazu führt,
dass ich das nicht möchte.
Ich weiss aber für die Therapie,
dass ich es trotzdem machen muss,
wenn ich gesund werden will,
und dass ich
die unangenehmen Gefühle,
die mit dem Essen verbunden sind,
aushalten muss.
Wenn ich nicht alles gegessen habe,
war wohl oft im Unterbewusstsein,
dass ich nicht weiter
dem Leben entgegengehen wollte,
dem, was das Leben halt ...
... beinhaltet.
Mit gewissen Dingen
umgehen zu müssen ...
Ja, mit einem ...
... gesunden Background
im Leben zu stehen
und die Krankheit nicht mehr als
Entschuldigung brauchen zu können.
Naera Giaimo
hat eine Wirtschaftsmittelschule,
schwer krank - noch abgeschlossen.
Seit November
bildet sie sich in Zürich
zur Medizinischen Sekretärin weiter.
Daneben braucht sie noch immer
viel Zeit für verschiedene Therapien.
Während der Dreharbeiten
entstand die Idee,
dass Naera und Flavia
sich kennenlernen könnten.
Flavia hat inzwischen
noch eine Chance bekommen
und darf ihre Therapie
unter strengen Auflagen weiterführen.
Hallo, ich bin Flavia.
- Hallo. Ich bin Naera.
Ich würde dir die Hand geben,
aber das ist nicht coronakonform.
Hoi, freut mich.
- Mich auch.
Schön, dass es geklappt hat.
- Ja, mega.
Ist das dein
erster Klinikaufenthalt?- Nein.
Nein, nein.
- Auch schon mehrere?
Ich bin seit acht Jahren ...
... in dem Zeugs drin.
Ich habe zwischendurch schon immer
wieder diese Stimme in meinem Kopf,
diese Zwänge,
aber ich kann mittlerweile
viel besser damit leben.
Und ich kann es auch ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Ich kann es ignorieren.
Nicht immer, aber schon viel besser.
Wenn ich jeweils in einer Klinik war
und Therapien hatte,
fragten mich die Leute manchmal,
wieso ich nicht arbeite.
Und ich fand:
"Ich mache einen 100-Prozent-Job,
um gesund zu werden."
Es ist harte Arbeit.
- Mega.
Aber ich finde, dass es sich
für mich gelohnt hat.- Wirklich?
Ich bin wirklich
viel, viel glücklicher.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wenn Sie sich beide einen guten
Wunsch auf den Weg geben müssten,
wie würde der lauten?
Dass sie noch ganz loslassen darf.
Und ich wünsche ihr, dass sie ...
... da rauskommt und das Leben
als gesunde Frau geniessen darf.
Und dass du deine Persönlichkeit
finden darfst ...
... und dich nicht
mit der Essstörung identifizierst.
Hoffnung liegt in der Luft,
als die beiden Frauen sich trennen.
Einen Monat später
dann aber die Hiobsbotschaft:
Flavia Maier schaffte es nicht,
weiter an Gewicht zuzulegen.
Eine Therapiepause verbrachte sie
zuerst in einem Pflegeheim,
danach bei ihren Eltern.
Die Magersucht hatte einmal mehr
die stärkeren Argumente.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021